das schon eine lustige geschichte wie
tanz und schaden von apple war pictures
sich kennen gelernt haben sie erzählen
es zum ersten mal im talk jetzt bei
klink zoom und genauso lustig ist die
geschichte was die kollegen von tans so
wissen was er in der freizeit so treibt
jetzt im talk bei clixoom bis dankbar an
wie ist die lage
jetzt war ja klar da verkommt habt ihr
euch gut vorbereitet ja ja diese frage
die frage ja die lage ist sensationell
ok einwandfreien einmal muss so wie es
muss wohl in der zeit alles super läuft
ja die abonnenten sind zufrieden das
merkt man daran dass der zuwachs ganz
cool ist ja
wir wir haben wieder mehr zeit
so ist muss es beim upgrade zeit
arbeitstechnisch ich muss nicht mehr so
viel lernen er hat ja demnächst sowieso
höhere ziele
und jetzt können wir wieder ganz auf
unsere auf unseren channel konzentriert
ich habe gerade noch okay
das video machen was hat das für eine
stellung in eurem leben ist dass der
mittelpunkt ein hobby oder beruf oder
berufung ich weiß ja dass es nicht ihr
beruf ist aber ist es für euch
eigentlich der beruf oder was ist es das
ist halt das was wir am liebsten machen
das ist halt die profession sein geld
verdienen denke ich mal erstmal
irgendwie aber das ist halt das was er
am liebsten macht
am anfang war das alles nur hobby ja
mittlerweile ist das
schon fast arbeit geworden ist ja ich
will es ja mal irgendwann arbeiten man
weiß es nicht man hofft deshalb ist das
eine gute arbeit wenn es eine arbeit
wäre ja es ist eine sehr gute arbeit
haben vier kanäle jetzt gerade so im
durchschnitt 1 spiele kanal
meerschweinchen kanal ein blog kanal und
den hauptkanal mit filme machen und eine
gute mischung macht unheimlich viel spaß
also es läuft unglaublich gut wie es ist
einfach so dass was du damals immer
gedacht haben so vor 56 jahren ich habe
nie mit gerechnet hätte das immer mal
in dem level machen wie ihr habt das
denn so durchgehalten solange
einfach immer weiter ich meine das wie
gesagt wir machen das halt am liebsten
warum dann damit aufhören irgendwann
leer so es ist zwar und das teuer ist je
mehr abonnenten man hat umso mehr leute
können sagen ja das finden wir toll und
dann macht die laune gleich viel mehr
spaß dann habe ich die motivation
einfach dazu ja man bringt ein video aus
das wird super oft geguckt die leute
finden es einfach toll dagegen nicht
geil nächstes nächstes mal noch ein
größeres noch besser okay aber
ihr oder anders gefragt du bist
stahlbauer ich bin starr betonmauern
vorher war ich landschaftsgärtner okay
jetzt stahlbetonbauer ein
wie ich es mir jetzt vorstelle im
klischee ein durchschnittlicher
stahlbetonbauer wenn dein arbeitstag
sind dann ist der platz und dann sagt
die freundin vielleicht noch jetzt bin
ich dran und da stellt sich mir immer
dass die große frage wie kann man dann
noch videos machen also so schwer wir
haben das filmemachen hauptsächlich fast
aufs wochenende über verlegt das sonst
nur sagen wir treffen uns immer und dich
zu phlox und so es war wirklich alles
nebenbei oder meerschweinchen film das
ich je öfter man es macht und je mehr
man es auch macht und wir wollen das ja
auch wir sagen ja auch immer jeweils
schon und so vielleicht mal zwei bis
drei blocks pro woche meerschweinchen
film einmal in der woche und an die
programmleiter will und dann ja haben
inspiriert je nachdem wie gerade breit
ist und dann auch über mehrere drehtage
das kann ich schon mal stressig werden
das ist aber normal wert haben uns auch
immer dabei ja auch tommy und adi die
wohnung ja wir wohnen jetzt zusammen ja
wir haben uns regelmäßig dabei das am
freitag immer noch bis spät in die nacht
oder bis samstag morgens noch schneiden
ohne ende damit am samstag dann doch
noch im film rauskommt ja weil wir uns
am samstag festgesetzt normalerweise
samstag ist apple waters und das kann
schon mal sehr kritisch werden
wir haben eure freunde nutzen
die machen alle mit
das hat sich ja mittlerweile okay ist
dass der ist dass der clou das man
einfach die freundin mit rein nimmt ja
es hilft ja oder ja kann man so sagen
und was ich eher seite wie viele leute
seite zusammen 16 jetzt rechts den
flüssen meerschweinchen kurz ein
meerschweinchen ich sehe hier muss das
mal zeit ich muss auch mal kurzzeitig
man muss eben nummer die büchereien
greifen nah du kannst sagt
er will nicht genau die weichen sind
immer dabei
aber wie seid ihr so eine riesen truppe
geworden weil das immer schon so oder
seid ihr so dass der held raum gewesen
und das ist ja das faszinierende gewesen
wir haben damals gesagt ja es gibt so
viele schlechte scheiß deutsche filme
das können wir besser haben dann
angefangen haben erst mal direkt
verschiffen volles rohr von mit anlage
aber wichtiger das heißt ihr habt euch
gesagt wir sind die tollsten und ja dann
habe ich gedacht wir direkt auf die
fresse gelehrt aber wir haben aber auch
gemerkt dass das eigentlich nur ganz
kontonummer die selbstironie durch zu
bewegen sondern muss so durch zu machen
wir auch heute noch das so und sagen ja
kommen wir sind die schlechtesten und
die dümmsten zeigen wir den anderen
ruhig ja wobei das ist ja nicht mehr der
fall ihr seid ja nicht ewig wir wissen
es ja wir wissen das ja auch selbst dass
wir gut sind sonst wären wir auch nicht
immer mehr filme machen aber aber wenn
man sich halt nicht selbst ernst nimmt
es halt immer schon gut und ich hatte am
anfang waren beweglich nur wir beide als
wir waren am anfang wir beide dass er
das gesagt haben oder damals hat man
noch einen anderen kollegen der ist dann
ja auch weggezogen oder ansonsten ist es
immer mal ab und zu wechseln dann ist
das immer mehr geworden immer dann immer
mehr freunde hinzugekommen die haben
dann immer mitgemacht dann kam noch drei
fans die haben in hagen gewohnt wie
dieser master games shorty und lost
empor die haben dann mal einfach haben
uns mal getroffen dann sagt mit direkt
ins team klar dass das direkt die haben
uns ja damals noch auf myvideo zeit als
du auf myvideo noch kennen und haben
gesagt ja egal kommt auch sagen können
wir mit spielen und so wie wir spielen
auch alles was ihr wollt irgendwie ein
hut ständer oder eine leichte keine
ahnung und dann hat es exakt zwei jahre
gedauert bis
das treffen dann aber zustande gekommen
ist aber seitdem sind sie dabei ok und
das macht es leichter oder schwieriger
kommt drauf an was gedreht wird also
wenn man muss so ein dreher wir mit viel
leben zu koordinieren dass auch wirklich
etwas zu tun hat weil sonst langweilt
sich da irgendjemand dann wird nämlich
abgelenkt und so also man muss immer
gucken dass man die alles ein bisschen
verteidigt ok und wer macht das
ja mit der lautesten stimme meine rolle
unter anderem wenn ihr sitzt im
hintergrund was sagen denn eure kollegen
am arbeitsplatz wirkt sich das auf eure
jobs
nicht so konzentriert oder oder kann man
da wirklich so eine trennung machen sagt
job ich sage das sehr kalt war in meinem
büro weiß das niemand und das ist auch
gut so das weiß keiner das weiß niemand
ach ist das auch okay so ist auch
unglaublich dass das immer noch keiner
was auch immer noch keiner mitgekriegt
und wenn die mich immer mal fragen wenn
ich dann sagen ja klar das ist mein
hobby was mach ich halt nach meiner
freizeit wenn ich von der arbeit weg
gehen und das ist okay und hat sich
niemand einzumischen und
auf der arbeit ist das halt und ich
trenne das aber auch so also ich kümmere
mich auf der arbeit nicht irgendwie
großartig irgendwelche apple walken oder
so sondern wird von der arbeit komme
dann fange ich dann damit dass dann mein
zweiter arbeitstag beginnt dann aber wir
sind bei dir ja komplett anders rum
das ist kein scherz was ich denke auch
irgendwie 24 stunden am tag ans
filmemachen so ungefähr ich setze darauf
arbeite ich habe mir heftig habe ein
handy und stehen dann eben auf facebook
twitter alles ja immer wenn es ins bett
geht und alles ist schon manchmal ein
bisschen sehr kompliziert wenn man sich
dabei immer bestand und auch wenn ich
dann ideen habe ich jetzt genau die idee
und ich weiß genau wenn ich jetzt die
idee für den film warum das nicht sofort
aufschreiben dann ist die direct die
idee wieder weg das habe stehen handys
ungefähr 150 ideen für filme und dann
hat er mir noch ein buch geschenkt das
schreibe ich die ganzen ideen auch noch
rein und alles und ich erwische mich
dabei wie ich auch wirklich under und
dann auch wenn ich auch momente
rumstehen und sagt ich habe nichts zu
tun auch direkt sowie mache ich den
nächsten film was plan nicht da und
alles also jetzt als beim stahlbau warum
geht das beim stallbau ja aber das
gerade auch noch auf meine arbeit
konzentrieren wie das ist das ist das
oder ich persönlich erlebt dabei wenn
ich handwerklich arbeite dann denke ich
immer nicht kann sich abschalten sagen
wir mal so ich krieg' ich hin also ich
kann es wirklich nicht abschalten das
ist einfach so
ab und zu wenn ich dann nicht ernsthaft
konzentrieren muss oder so aber wenn ich
jetzt einfach mal so einen tag habe
wurde dann eine stunde am tag warum
stehst oder da gar nichts machen muss
oder dann immer direkt über nachdenken
oder in den pausen dann 70 auch mal da
und schreibt drehbücher oder bright
irgendwas vor gedanklich und was sagen
deine kollegen alle meine kollegen
wissen dass sogar meine chefs die frage
mich immer ja wann hörst du denn endlich
hier auf
erstmals macht das nochmals beruf haben
bisher nicht weg also natürlich im
positiven positiven also versteht sich
mit denen gut ja wir wissen dass einige
von uns sind auch fans ist total lustig
also derart sowie wir haben ein arzt
sowie der iss
aus den oststaaten euro und so glaubt
man ja oft chaos das ist der beste da
mal drüber da kann man auf der baustelle
ja erstes lehrjahr da kann man hinterher
sah mich da wäre fast in den abgrund
gefallen das war total klasse
was machst du ja ich arbeite hier
gesprächsthema siehst du das denn auch
so dass du denkst hey ich muss da
mehr aus diesem video bereich machen
oder denkst du dir hey das ist ein super
job stahlbetonbauer und ich will dass
immer weiter so nebenbei machen wie ist
eure
dazu wollte irgendwann mal ganz rein
oder lieber den job als sicherheit oder
was hat weil wir haben ja eine zeit des
umbruchs das geht immer das wird immer
größer es wird immer mehr ich sag mal
spätestens seit letztem jahr ist youtube
ein massenmedium glaubt unglaublich
absolut planen sind ja was ist denn
daran da was geht im kopf
wir denken wie ich ja wenn das
irgendwann mal klappt dass die
möglichkeit besteht ich bin sofort weg
aber das alles gesichert ist also ist
alles gesichert sein ich kann jetzt
nicht einfach sagen so ja ich ja jetzt
sofort auf ja dass das geht nicht es
muss immer dahinter sein dass wir sagen
ja ich habe mindesteinkommen dass ich
leben kann und alles aber wenn sich das
irgendwann mal breit macht was du sagst
ja immer um gut über die runden direkt
weg nur noch filme machen während raum
ok jetzt auch machen denkt schon ja wenn
die sicherheit da wäre aber das muss man
halt erstmal darum schon arbeiten aber
das habe ich diego ab und zu
risikobereit irgendwo muss man da drin
sein aber auch mein leben lang auf der
baustelle
und es ist ja nicht so dass ich dass ich
meine fähigkeiten die ich in meinem job
jetzt erworben habe dort nicht
gebrauchen könnte so allein so diese
ganzen kaufmännischen sachen die kemna
unserer firma das ist ja
ich brauch noch mal eben set auf wäre
hier ja genau auch im vergleich genau
das duo hatte am anfang habe ich brauch
mal die belege also du könntest wirklich
dafür die firma das auch machen naja
steuerfachangestellter ja
ja wobei die unsicherheit geht ja glaube
ich nie weg weil man muss sich ja darauf
verlassen dass das funktioniert und man
weiß ja nie ob man immer populär ist
oder oder oder na ja also ich meine man
bei ihm wäre sowieso kein problem so
kopf mäßig wollen selbstständigkeit
bedeutet halt selbst und ständig
arbeitet und so magath da könnte ich
mich dann auch endlich darauf einlassen
so nicht von der arbeit kommt ich halte
nur einen arbeitstag aber der inhalt 24
stunden ja das ist das tolle an dem film
machen ist man setzt sich der handle
sich ja geil ja ich habe jetzt mache
dann ziehe ich das durch dann steinemann
dran dann ist man immer gut gelaunt
finde ich also ich es ist ein
unterschied ob ich jetzt arbeiten die
acht stunden oder neun stunden oder vom
filme sitzen drehen schneiden das kann
ich acht bis zwölf stunden damals mich
überhaupt nicht ja ich hab doch erst
einmal überdenken das macht einfach spaß
ja und das ist halt gesagt das ist halt
dieses hobby könnte zum beruf werden und
wenn ein hobby ist das macht es dir spaß
macht
ist dann aber euer bisheriger beruf ist
kein frust nein sondern was ist das das
ist ein beruf den ich gerne mache sonst
hätte ich mir nicht ausgesucht ich sags
ja immer wenn ihr der beruf keinen spaß
macht hat den falschen beruf ganz
einfach ja und wie gesagt das ist auch
die erweiterung dieser fähigkeiten halt
ich habe dann auch kenntnisse im
kaufmännischen bereich ne
eben halt mal etwas gesagt für mich ist
das halt so ich hab damals
landschaftsgärtner gelernt das habe ich
nicht bereut braucht man immer ich habe
jetzt stahlbetonrohre gelernt wenn ich
selbst mache zusätzlich kann ich habe
zwei ausbildung komplett abgeschlossen
war
wenn sie das irgendwann mal aufhört
jetzt sagt keine anderen sagte ja ich
habe keine ausbildung gemacht ja ich
habe lange genug drin gearbeitet der
sommer nicht verschwendete zeit gewesen
das ist wo hass 2 ausbildung und du hast
gearbeitet
das ist ja nicht verschwendet wenn jetzt
mal vollzeit youtuber werden solltest
das sind ja nicht verschwindet ja das
ist ja nicht so dass ich jetzt zehn
jahre arbeitslos war und
ja nichts gemacht habe aber wann war dem
wo ist noch mal die you ist jetzt der
gedanke entstanden hey das könnte man
professionell machen und wie stellt sich
also habe ich irgendwann aufgestanden
und dann habe ich gedacht ich bin jetzt
so berühmter als so was im moment
irgendwie wird dass das ist ein gedanke
er schleppt sich immer hinterher ich
jetzt noch nicht realisiert wie viel
würde das richtig wenn wir auf
conventions gehen wir sind ja stark mit
anime manga bereich tätig aber wenn man
auf conventions gehen letztes jahr
japan-tag
verletzt aber adam und sieben leute
erkannt ja letztes jahr japan-tag er
konnten wir uns nicht bewegen da nehmen
wir bekamen oft in japan beendet das war
der tagen ja ja ja stimmen drei stunden
sind 20 minuten gegangen schau mal zwei
stunden am ende das war der japan tag
für uns und so gehen aber alle ko
menschen auf wir kommen dahin ja morgen
ist die doku me ja
dass auch eine anime und manga kommen
wir schnell da kommen dann in diese zwei
tage sind wir ganz samstag da wir geben
wir gehen wie wissen wir gehen jetzt
kannst du hin weil viele leute wissen
dass wir da sind und wir gehen jetzt
dahin und sagen dann stellen muss erst
mal zwei bis vier stunden fans ich
komplett bis keiner mehr kommt und dann
drehen wir schönen film darüber mit
tape.tv kommen auch da freuen uns darauf
die machen mit und also
rein wachsen ja es waren rein wachsen
kann man kann man nicht lange und denkst
dir so er geistig fitter youtube das ist
damals haben wir immer gesagt genau das
ist diese hürde die wir damals gesagt
haben
bewusst hat unserem ganzen kreis hinter
dieser alle florida bleibt raimund
damals damals mal gesagt und lord aber
noch immer gesagt so wenn du mal
100.000 abonnenten hassen sie genauso ab
100.000 abonnenten bisschen in
deutschland groß dann hast du es
geschafft so jetzt haben 133000 und
denken uns immer noch realer geht noch
da geht noch was ich damit auch seit
geraumer zeit habe der wahnsinnige abo
zu wechseln also wenn der jetzt 133000
sagen wenn das video online geht könnten
schon 150.000 seien ja ja ein wahnsinn
und nach so und angst dass wirklich ja
von 300 bis 800 täglich damals hat man
sich nur über 20 oder 40 gefreut ich
weiß noch wie wir uns monatelang wollte
vorher also hier wenn ich 40 uhr
ortszeit wieder zu tag wo die radler
wurde es war absoluter klasse ja und alt
ist das so es ist unglaublich aber immer
noch daran wächst dann denkt man sich so
ein tag hat man vielleicht nutzen da
denkt man sich a nur 200 ja und andere
leute die wünschten die hätten dass man
ja immer so unglaublich
also dann liegt das was macht euch so
populär habt ihr irgendwie ich weiß
nicht ob das mal so festgestellt das ist
wie bei uns in dieser wg schauen ist und
auch der da wie mit also die 16 leute
auch leute gerade dieses team das die
unterschiedlichen charaktere jeder ist
anders da ist ja nicht wie das immer
zwei das gleiche machen oder so es ist
ja echt unterschiedliche töpfe aber ich
habe da können sich viele mit
identifizieren so mit sich und ihrem
freundeskreis vielleicht auch so und ich
hab das macht unter anderem so ein
bisschen was von der popularität aus das
ist jeder da spielt man auch ja mal
macht kann man sich denn leute er macht
man ein video mit zehn und dann schreien
andere leute ja wo ist los die gewesen
wo ist der gewesen leider fehlt an das
ja welche die haben den vermisst habt
ihr den rausgeschmissen rutschte ich den
leuten vom fach
deshalb haben wir auch hier sind ja 16
leute haben uns gesagt jetzt machen also
so irgendwie serien wo man sich alle
treffen und dann haben wir angefangen
mit diesem nerds versus ja je mehr leute
da so nun so besser wird die folge alles
klasse oder feine frustration brauchen
wir auch über viele leute was meint ihr
was er macht wenn ihr mal 60 seid dann
sind für die youtube rentner programm
was gibt's da mit sicherheit schon oder
aber nicht wenn nicht dann sind wir die
ersten lieder und youtube rentenprogramm
kommen ich beobachte einfach doktor
allwissend dann weiß ich dass er ist
jetzt auch schon
nicht so alt aber der ist älter als wir
und mal gucken was der dann macht ein
kopieren wir das genau wir kopieren
einfach doch dabei wissen die zeit man
kennt ihr euch eigentlich
seitdem er nicht beim zahnarzt hinterher
genauso dem wir sind nicht beim zahnarzt
war weil ich weil ich mal den fahrern
vermied vergessen habe irgendwann
einfach nach der schule bin ich mit dem
bus nach hause und dann hat dieser typ
da gesessen mit einem final fantasy
artbook und final fantasy
videospielreihe sind wahrscheinlich und
ich da jetzt auch eingelöst weil das ist
schon cool und er so er
mal gucken und dann das gespräch
gekommen mich mitgenommen wir direkt mit
nach hause genommen hat sich
herausgestellt dürfte gar nicht in dem
bus seien weil ich halt so eine zahl
sollte aber naja so kann's gehen durch
solche zu vernünftige war trifft man
dann halt irgendwie menschen und gründet
irgendwelche firmen
und wie lang ist das jetzt schon lang
ist es her da war ich glaube ich 15 war
metal gear solid 1 gerade draußen ja
ich denke mal ich aus 15 und was glaube
ich 21 wenigen schon 120 christen
1919 glaube ja ja und als so alt ich
meine da ist der altersunterschied
später ja doch mal gesagt jetzt leben ja
klein geblieben ist also wir waren
sowieso 15 das meine ich das problem ich
habe erst mal bei mir ist das so ich
sehe alle erst mal als freund anja mit
ihm kommt man sicher von vornherein gut
unterhalten ist ja nicht so dass wir
gedacht das war das jetzt ein kleiner
vollidiot oder so deshalb das war auch
der ausschlaggebende und was war was ist
schon basis aller freundschaft hat
worauf wir haben halt über über games
die anzeige und als ständig auch games
gezockt auch dachte vielleicht zudem dem
zweitplatzierten spielen soll
habe ich zu hause auch also das ist ja
eine frau spielt hatte damals wohl wie
gesagt haben ja final fantasy war die
grundlage waren halt echt spieler lagen
damals war es echt alles spiele aller
spiele aber irgendwann gesagt hier ich
habe keinen bock mehr als spielen ich
will die story sehen hier spiel mir das
vor und habt ihr hilft da das spiel soll
der kontrollaufwand grillwagen spiel so
dass nicht er hat keine
zwischensequenzen und
sagt komm spiel das man
und wann 19
der wert soll dass die waffe in die hand
das erste was bin ich eigentlich sagen
dumme sprüche komm mal die ganze zeit ja
daneben ermittelte dass das ist bei uns
in komplette war und so ist eigentlich
das freundliche worte
mittelstück der sage ich hey du sagen
hey arschloch da wird alles klar ist es
einfach bei uns eigentlich nicht also ja
ich heute haben uns noch nie gestritten
glaube ich
man muss auch bitte nicht kommen besser
nicht nee muss ich nicht haben weil dann
stirbt er ich glaube auch wenn das
irgendwann mal passiert dann wir haben
wir die linke alle bei mir
was ist aber ich meine er hat ein riesen
freundeskreis und viele leute heute sind
alleine haben vielleicht eine freundin
manchmal aber was ist so etwas ist
wichtig um gute freunde zu haben ist das
video machen so eine basis oder hat sich
tim wunderbar ist auch ja es bildet halt
irgendwie jeder hat von denen aus
unserer gruppe hat in die box irgendwas
zu kreieren zu machen sich immer wieder
auszuleben das werden auch mal geil
effekte drüber gelegt und musik und so
und sind ja aber nicht tanzen sehen
einfach daneben so etwas mitgemacht hat
und ich glaube das ist einfach irgendwie
macht was zusammen ich einfach nach
draußen sein muss sind auch an der
frischen luft meistens wenn wir nicht
gerade irgendwie berliner bruder hängen
das ist schon ein unterschied also
besser als zusammenlaufen gehen ja oder
kiffen oder noch über die jugendlichen
nächste 50.000 abo saufen kommt der
wieder die köpfe aber das ist ja was
anderes das ist ja das ist ja nicht um
jetzt die langeweile zu bekämpfen gehen
wir jetzt ganz laufen sondern wir machen
halt wir gehen mal was laufen wenn
vorher gelaufen
und wenn ich also no drugs wachsen und
wachsen ich brauche aber noch nie im
leben echt natur ist
ja auch so gut gelaunt ich auch das
alles nicht woher kommt die
mega gute laune ich denke mir mal warum
nur warum sollte ich schlechte laune
haben wenn ich gute laune haben macht
viel mehr spaß es ist einfach so ich
weiß ich habe immer gute laune weil mir
das schlechte laune haben nichts nützt
und das geht dir nicht tierisch auf den
sack wieso ich habe auch eigentlich
macht gute laune also das ist ja wir
raten wir machen halt in unserer
freizeit das was uns am meisten spaß
macht und das ist irgendwie
noch nicht erfüllt dann hoffe ich dass
ihr noch viele viele jahre sehr erfüllt
sein
ich hoffe ihr habt eine menge spaß
gehabt beim talk hier mit apple pictures
und habt eine menge interessantes
erfahren das werde er auch erfahren wenn
ihr auf bülent ceylan hier klickt der
erzählt nämlich ich war verzweifelt als
seine karriere nicht so richtig losging
und spannend auch der türke mit white it
nämlich ihr großes geheimnis verraten
werden im talk also wenn er das erfahren
wollt klickt darauf ansonsten bis dann
daran